dernier jour de tournage pour l'équipe
du film adrénaline le réalisateur nadir
you lie in originaire de la verrière
réalise son quatrième projet un court
métrage qui emmène les spectateurs dans
les quartiers ce matin là les séquences
en motocross sont filmés en réalité
virtuelle 360
quand vous mettez un casque et que vous
retrouvé immergé dans un univers vous
êtes témoin vous êtes le même personnage
c'est une expérience tout le court
métrage eux seraient en réalité
virtuelle pour la captation il utilise
une caméra en 8k avec six objectifs
le but pour le réalisateur mélanger la
réalité virtuelle en 360 avec les
histoires du monde urbain dans le
premier rôle aziz diabaté connu pour
avoir joué dans les séries télévisées
les bras des rouges est ici tout
commence à me donne à dire you lie in il
a tout de suite accepté le rôle de
azzedine mon personnage il est un peu
comme moi trop la bécane il y bien dans
sa vie kiffe les gens c'est pas un
vicieux il est gentil et engrais va lui
arriver une galère parce que les autres
qu'il a acheté ben en fait à partir
d'autres mecs et le dha qu'il achetait
ben en fait il la voulait et voilà
comment commence histoire sur le
tournage beaucoup de jeunes des cités
avoisinantes étaient autorisés à venir
voir les scènes et certains ont même
participé dans le but d'initier les
jeunes aux métiers de l'imagerie
numérique et du cinéma
tous les jeunes rats qui ont participé
du bois de l'étang du val hibou
d'elancourt ils découvrent ces métiers
là learning by doing il les découvre
invivo s'il n'y a pas trop de théorie en
fait ils viennent poser la question à
comment on fait si comment on fait ça et
le voyons pratiques y voit comment on
doit cacher un micro pourquoi on doit
cacher le fait de jouer un rôle faire
paraître quelque chose quelque chose de
faux tout est intéressant
franchement tomblaine le court métrage
devrait être sorti début juillet est
proposé dans différents festivals